A few versions of Batman's sidekick Robin
have appeared in live-action films, but there
are a lot more we've still yet to see.
Which one might best fit into the universe
of "The Batman"?
Keep watching for the answer.
When director Matt Reeves' "The Batman" premieres
in the U.S. on March 4, 2022, it will mark
the first standalone live-action Batman movie
since Christopher Nolan's "The Dark Knight
Rises" in 2012.
Robert Pattinson will be donning the cowl,
he'll be teaming up with Zoe Kravitz as Catwoman,
and they'll be taking on a whole host of threats.
There's Paul Dano's The Riddler, a Zodiac
killer-inspired take on the character who's
trying to expose Gotham's elites.
There's also Colin Farrell as The Penguin,
and John Turturro as the gangster Carmine
Falcone.
Batman will luckily get a little moral support
from Bruce Wayne's longtime butler, Alfred
Pennyworth, played by Andy Serkis.
As is always the case with a new Batman movie,
one big question is whether Robin will be
part of the story.
Unfortunately for fans of Batman's stalwart
sidekick, Robin isn't in the mix this time,
though Reeves hasn't ruled him out in the
future.
"Holy heartbreak."
So far, Robin has shown up just a few times
in live-action movies.
He was played by Douglas Croft and Johnny
Duncan in the often-forgotten "Batman" movie
serials in the 1940s, and Burt Ward played
Robin in the 1966 live-action "Batman" film
alongside Adam West.
Chris O'Donnell played him in both 1995's
"Batman Forever" and 1997's "Batman & Robin."
Like Croft and Ward's Robins, this was the
Dick Grayson version of the character, a traveling
acrobat whose family is tragically killed.
"The Dark Knight Rises" had an original character
with similarities to Robin, John Blake, who
was played by Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
He's a Gotham City cop who works with Batman
and later reveals…
"You should use your full name.
I like that name.
Robin."
"Thanks."
That leaves a slew of DC Comics versions of
Robin that may have shown up on TV and in
animated productions, but have never appeared
in a live-action film.
Pattinson told Collider he's up for adding
Robin, with conditions:
"Yeah, but he has to be 13.
That's the only way I'll accept it.
No, I love 'Death in the Family' and stuff,
but I think it'd be so cool.
Also people are so scared of it, but it's
kind of exciting.
I think it would be a really fun addition."
"Death in the Family" is the 1988 comics story
in which the Jason Todd version of Robin is
killed by the Joker.
Todd is an orphan and the second individual
to take up the Robin mantle after Dick Grayson
aged out of it.
Later, Todd is resurrected as the vigilante
superhero Red Hood who, unlike Batman, has
no moral qualms about killing criminals.
The Jason Todd arc, including the resurrection,
would seem to fit right in with the dark tone
Reeves is establishing with "The Batman."
There's also the third Robin, Tim Drake.
He's the third iteration of Robin, who after
figuring out both Batman and Robin's real
identities, approaches Bruce Wayne and asks
to become his next sidekick.
Bruce trains Drake into one of the best martial
artists and detectives in the world.
Drake eventually ages out of the role, too,
after which he takes on a new name, Red Robin.
If Reeves really wanted to throw a curveball,
he'd go with the Stephanie Brown version of
Robin.
She's a street vigilante and the daughter
of the supervillain Cluemaster, who starts
her career as the costumed hero Spoiler.
She briefly claims the Robin mantle but is
fired for disobeying orders.
She later becomes Batgirl.
Or there's the fifth and most recent Robin,
Damian Wayne, Bruce Wayne's son with Talia
al-Ghul.
Since Talia appeared in "The Dark Knight Rises"
and had a brief relationship with Bruce, and
since "The Batman" is a wholesale reboot of
the franchise, this one seems less likely.
There's also Carrie Kelley from Frank Miller's
"The Dark Knight Returns," who spent some
time as Robin in a version of Batman's very
late career.
It's also entirely possible that Reeves could
follow Nolan and go with something new.
Before he can do that, "The Batman" must first
deliver at the box office.
The good news is the critics mostly love it
so far.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.